my guest tonight is a comedian who's
appeared in numerous films including
getting to the Greek and forgetting
sarah marshall now he has his own weekly
podcast entitled under the skin that's a
podcast I'd listen to he has a
fascinating mind please welcome Russell
Brand Russell
how are you sometimes I feel like a part
of the lockdown is I'm finding it
difficult to motivate myself I can tell
by looking at you are you an expert in
body language I am well I don't think
you have to be an expert in body
language - no you look like a 90 year
old woman recovering from a stroke are
you okay yeah I feel very optimistic and
full of beans and vim and vigor and
vitality
okay good you've got vim vitality and
vigor you're full of beans no one's
talked that way in 60 years Russell I
love your outfit you're wrapped in
towels it looks like you're what's
happening this is month most favorite
blanket bequeathed to me by Mahatma
Gandhi not directly it was someone
someone took it in East London when he
visited and you can almost smell the
transcendence
anyway it's delicious
sometimes when you use a hearse
detergent you can wash out the
transcendence I'm glad you didn't do
that mas you know so we have a lot to
talk about first of all Jeff Jeff Jeff
just is your producer Jeff just chatting
to his family okay well you tries to
continue obviously with your Jill I am
the I am the opposite of it yeah that
one called Jeff and tell him to shut up
here I'll call him right now Jeff we're
trying to do an interview here and we're
hearing everything you're saying that's
cuz I had my mic on yes I know I know
/ now oh my god Russell I apologize that
was in
really unprofessional not up to the
standards that you've set with the way
you're dressing no way you're lying I
come here on to your show in the blanket
of a latter-day Saint and you insult me
with Jeff leaving his mic on on zoom' a
terrible terrible let me set the table
for our viewers Russell you are in
London right now as I correct I'm in the
countryside outside of London where some
years ago I escaped to to bucolic bliss
to have a family and to explore
different states of consciousness
without chemicals very nice and how's
that working for you I miss the
chemicals a nice London you're married
now and you have children is that right
yeah I've got two children and I didn't
know how much feces would be involved
Conan yes they they tend to do that yes
very grounding isn't it well yes I have
two children but they're older now
they're teenagers and they're still
quite a lot of feces I'll be honest with
you mm-hmm
that sand happens well into adulthood
I'm looking forward to at least a decade
and a half of excretion okay well listen
here's what I want to get to Russell
when I first met you you were a wild man
you wore tight leather pants you prowled
the streets like a lion
you were very sexually active and in
fact you talked very frankly about your
sex addiction and now look at you
wrapped like a saint
in white blankets in bucolic bliss in
the countryside with a wife and children
what was that transition like in a way
it's a cliched journey isn't it from
excess to conversion and to the embrace
of the spiritual life but what I was
told is that all of these energies we
put into drugs and promiscuity are
yearning for a kind of wholeness a
connection to the limitless access to
the sacred
and the divine if you can't get those
things simply acquire yourself for
blankets and wait for time to pass you
know I read that once on a box of herbal
tea it sounds like a cliche but it's
just true the there's a hole in all of
us that makes us see that's probably why
you and I got into comedy isn't it
yes I think initially I was drawn to
committee for approval for the
possibility of of orgasm primarily you
not on stage you didn't want to have the
orgasm on stage did you you just meant
that comedy would lead you towards the
opposite sex and then there'd probably
be an orgasm how I mean I wonder how
many of human endeavors from a manned
space flight to the advent of the
spinning jenny in in Victorian London do
you think were ultimately motivated by
the need for that kind of fulfillment
that manner of fulfillment Russell I
agree I think the Wright brothers built
that plane just to get laid I really do
I think they wanted to fly to a nearby
farm impress the ladies with their
flying machine and then we'll go and
Orville we're gonna get it on with some
of the local ladies I think he would
explain to Wilbur Wilbur and Orville
this in your case will not lead to
sexual opportunity just being an answer
in Trivial Pursuit and and
disappointment maybe they wouldn't
oppose it you know yeah yeah maybe they
wouldn't have built the plane we
wouldn't have an airplane now if it
wasn't for a human need for sex it could
be seen as the drive behind many many
things but I suppose my point no Conan
and I'll sweep my blanket behind my ear
to make it very managing to maintain
I've been maintaining this myself since
high school this
get up in the morning and it takes very
little work a little mayonnaise a
baker's kill about 45 minutes at 600
degrees and look it's done look at that
was it an incredible scalp that you've
got there and I must say that for you to
maintain those standards I didn't
imagine that this would be something
that you'd be able to sustain during the
lockdown therefore the first thing to go
would be the altitude of your quiff this
is my way of supporting the world this
is my way of showing that we cannot give
up we cannot give in this is my
statement your hair follicles are like
the Ravens in the tower at the Tower of
London as long as your hair follicles
are upright we are okay
yeah like Churchill's cigar was a mighty
phallic symbol a sort of tobacco penis
in the face of Nazi Germany nor hair
that magnificent Auburn edifice is a
hall that will protect us if not from
the virus itself then certainly from the
dispiriting effects of the virus you
know Russell that's that's so kind but I
do think you hit the nail on the head my
quiff as you call it my pompadour this
massive Belgian pastry that I wear on my
head is my defiance it is my way of
saying stand back virus you shall not
pass ya no pasa nada they say yeah well
done I mean it's like a hinge I think in
generations to come druids may gather
around what remains of that glorious now
Russell I have to ask you are you still
wearing the tight leather trousers
because you wore them very well and I
say that with great respect but no one
rocked leather trousers like you but now
I see you almost in this mother Teresa
mode
do you still break out the leather
trousers every now and that I became
vegan some time ago due to the nagging
the constant
cultural nagging to become vegan and so
like I do have tight uncomfortable age
inappropriate leg wear but I can slip on
if I'm required to perform lives but
they're they're not leather anymore and
look do what is the myth of the wild man
who is the wild man the wild man is a
figure that we need to maintain in
culture because we know in our hearts
that civilization is temporary or show
the Great Sage and some would say
crackpot said what is civilization but a
clearing in the forest and now isn't it
becoming evident clear that all of our
constructs all of our concepts all of
our systems our civilization is
crumbling around us what then if you
have no access to the wild man what then
if you can't call upon a bearded
gentleman in pleather trousers to thrust
you forward into a revolutionary new era
what then I ask you Conan okay
Russell while you were ranting I called
the police
and the matter they're going to break
down break out your door in about two
minutes just go with them and when they
give you a pill take it and you'll have
a nice sleep okay
the British Constabulary would have more
respect to arrest an Englishman in his
own home blanket
an Irish descended living monument to
paganism now I'm told it are we limited
somewhat by the life of your battery of
your computer is that right your battery
is running low is that correct
no the reason aren't the only limitation
is you know the limitations have already
been placed upon us in fact that this
phone is plugged into the wall which
prohibits my motion more than I would
like but to be honest Conan what would I
do would I be pure letting around the
room I mean what would one do what would
one do this is I like you this way if
you're very christ-like thank you
you are a Buddha you represent in this
mode right now perennialism aldous
huxley called that recognizing the
underlying archetypal connections that
unifying all theology and and religious
faiths guess what you're on American
television
you have to dumb it down let's talk
about your podcast I love that you have
a podcast because you have a very
perceptive mind
I've always enjoyed talking to you are
you trying to probe what's really going
on under the surface of the people
you're discussing and you find that
you're very good at it I would think you
would be this podcast I do on a platform
called luminary that requires that
people subscribe to it what I do on
there is I talk to people that has a
kind of areas of expertise and advanced
knowledge and I try to convert it into a
language that anybody would understand
now you've already bellowed directly as
a camera that I need to be less esoteric
and you've also threatened to call the
police genuinely trying to investigate
the possibility of organizing systems in
a different way talking to
astrophysicists political professors
philosophers and my hope Coenen is it
that it's somewhat humorous and
accessible to all that's the point of
under the skin I would like to have you
on the show if you would deign to be on
it I would like to investigate you I
would like to understand you just for
our viewers right now could you give me
just a thumbnail sketch of what's
happening with Conan O'Brien through the
laser light glare of Russell Brand
you are a puckish figure and whilst you
present yourself as accessible and warm
you have a deep sense of comic mischief
which can lead to destruction
I would sense possibly in your home life
I imagine your wife detest you
and I think you're probably only one
malt base to drink away from reaching
havoc on you and you on yourself your
family your nation the trickster is to
be destructive and it's like thank God
that the profession of talk-show host
was invented because what would you do
just talk about that monorail episode of
The Simpsons for the rest of your life
like you'd bring down the government
you'd be a dangerous man there's a seam
of radicalism in you and I'd be
interested investigating if I also know
you're very warm-hearted
and very beautiful and compassionate and
real so I'd probably explore that in the
last 10 minutes the nail on the head yes
especially they're not only the wife but
the children as well there is a loathing
just beneath the surface we're
quarantined together it's no coincidence
that when I walk into a room they walk
out of the room and quickly dude what do
we do I mean at least you probably had a
family a normal age I want to match what
you're doing as best I can to try and
create here a homeostasis if you will
we're in this it looks like something
from inception yeah anyone who's just
tuning in doesn't know what's happening
we look like two two old druids in a
sauna together beautifully cocooned
hostages of misfortune is how I would
describe this Conan Russell I have to be
honest with you it's hard for me not to
go to a sensual place in it's as if I
were lying alone with you in a bed in
the countryside outside London so
naturally one's mind starts to wander
one starts to imagine well this is what
it would be like to be lying in bed with
Russell Brand we would have fantastic
pillow talk you and I I mean the
conjugation itself I think would be
possibly repulsive but after we've got
through that ordeal my god
the analysis what were you thinking
tearing that bit Conan first of all
you're correct
whatever we managed to do together
physically it would not go well
awkward and there'd be a lot of
apologies afterwards we're very limited
brown limbs there would be elbows and
knees cracking about we'd be like two
lab skeletons that were thrown down a
hill together that's what it would be it
sound like if we went out but Meccano
with with ham just sprinkled in hair
yeah you know I'm happy to see but it
looks like you're enjoying your
existence as the docile connected
husband father yes is this correct I
enjoyed being sort of a famous person
for a while and I enjoyed the excitement
and approval and a short-lived accolades
etc but I felt I'm looking for something
more and only think part of the
reevaluation that will take place
automatically as a result of these
extraordinary conditions dear Conan my
sweet gentle lover my strawberry strewn
wonder man my you impish giant great
language creature you living sparkling
Emerald River people might be tempted to
put aside their constructions to which
they have been bound and investigate
different ways of living
isn't that a possibility I think it's a
possibility yeah well now I feel like
I'm straddling you
yeah oh yes yes this would be your view
if you were straddling me right now this
would be the view that you would have
you look startled well I think I would
be startled in that situation you know I
write to awaken and Russell Brand was
travelling me I wouldn't do it while
you're unconscious the hope you'd be
participating in the entire narrative up
to the point of the straddling I'd like
to feel your hands upon my hips your
breath upon my brow well I promise I
promise that if this ever is to happen
I'll be fully conscious thank you I'd
like to make the the same pledge I feel
like I might walk around a little bit if
I may I might go through several
lighting conditions we're probably going
to wrap this up soon it's been
absolutely what I would imagine that you
will I mean once we've you know played
out a scenario where we were strapped
past my kids rooms um want to like talk
through the straddling scenario where is
they really left for us to go murderer
you look like an intruder your own home
yes Conan I feel like an intruder in my
own home a refugee very good thank you
yeah with we passed the time with craft
activities is that the most English
thing you've ever seen there's a hound
ordinated with your personal
pigmentation we call that a dog we don't
call it a hound Russell I want to make
sure I get this out
download under the skin is terrific
podcasts available we're from luminary
media Russell I can't wait to see you in
the flesh
because we have opened a lot of
possibilities let's put it that way
we certainly a cultural has been opened
and I just hope to god we can shut it
Russell Brand absolute delight seriously
thank you very much for doing it be well
thank you for being here and please
apologize to your wife seeing my face at
any time of day when not expected is
horrifying
imagine when she gets the context and
the straddling stuff I mean poor woman
all right take care Russell see me